bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sur tv fil 78 nous sommes
ensemble jusqu'à 19 heures si vous nous
suivez en direct une heure pour faire le
point sur l'actualité locale et ce soir
je recevrai le responsable dans les
yvelines d'anticorps l'association lance
une pétition pour obliger les députés et
sénateurs ps a démissionné de leurs
mandats locaux comme il s'y était engagé
une pétition alors que lionel jospin
vient de faire le point cet après-midi
sur les travaux menés par sa commission
sur ce sujet également invité olivier de
la sphère le conseiller général
yvelinois qui porte la candidature de
versailles pour accueillir à la cité de
la gastronomie une cité de la
gastronomie française
nous en parlerons d'ici à la fin de
cette édition la suite du sommaire de ce
9 octobre en images à présent soirée de
prestige autour du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une visite de
chantier avec la fédération française de
cyclisme qui va s'y installer a lieu
actuellement une remise de trophées à de
grands noms est prévu nous aurons en
ligne à l'un de nos journalistes sur
place manifestation nationale à l'appel
de la cgt pour la défense de l'emploi
industriel aujourd'hui nous ferons le
point avec le délégué local à noste
oscille hier lundi les syndicalistes qui
ont été reçus par le président du
conseil général le maire du chesnay et
conseiller général philippe brillault a
fait voter une motion contre le projet
de loi en faveur du mariage homosexuel
il va nous expliquer sa position il sera
sur ce plateau façade
eddie aït conseiller régional et maire
de carrières sous poissy et puis vous le
voyez la nuit blanche ce n'était pas
qu'à paris s'était également à elancourt
samedi soir le quartier 17 mar a dévoilé
ses talents artistiques nous y étions
vous découvrirez le travail mené
notamment par le chorégraphe jean claude
gallotta
pour débuter ce 7,8 nous allons revenir
sur la mobilisation de la cgt des
manifestations ont eu lieu un peu
partout dans le pays aujourd'hui
principalement sur paris
d'emploi et industrie dans huit villes
aujourd'hui principalement à paris
c'était la première mobilisation sous
l'ère françois hollande alors que les
plans sociaux se multiplient notamment
dans le secteur de l'automobile
nous avons en ligne alain tailleur
bonsoir vous êtes bonsoir l'intérieur
vous êtes membre du bureau de la cgt
mines secrétaire général cgt au
technocentre renault à guyancourt
la cgt qui aujourd'hui était le seul
syndicat à appeler à la mobilisation
est ce que vous regrettez déjà cet
isolement nous on attend bien sûr ce
qu'ils allmand parce que l'ensemble des
fans des centrales syndicales des
chances comme 190 autres syndicats
européens appelaient aujourd'hui un fait
manifestation donc est ce un grand ni
sang ni telles centrales syndicales ont
fais appeler une fille at rassemblement
force est de constater qu'il n'était pas
sur le terrain et j'y suis j'y étais la
cgt aujourd'hui vous travaillez au
technocentre renault à guyancourt
quelle a été la mobilisation aujourd'hui
au technocentre renault à guyancourt
clairement la mobilisation en pleine
tension entre nos n'a pas été à la
hauteur des enjeux de
l'industrialisation de l'emploi
industriel en france parce que sans
doute la pression et les ja en général
et la pression qui peut y avoir sur
l'emploi aujourd'hui il
participent à une mobilisation massive
des salariés et la manipulation
aujourd'hui ce que vous vous sentez
véritablement menacée malgré justement
cette mobilisation a ses faiblesses que
vous est ce que les salariés présents se
sont menacés d'une perte d'emploi on
peut aussi citer 1 pour le cas de
renault votre entreprise en ce moment du
côté de flins une mobilisation aussi
puisqu'on dénonce des situations de
sous-effectifs alors que vont sortir sur
le marché la clio iv et la zoé tout à
fait tout à fait alors qu'elle soit en
production comme à flins que vous
vouliez de les oublier
on est fiers la clio 4 qui va être
majoritairement fabriquée à bursa en
turquie il y aura bien sûr un complément
fabriquée à flins avec la levure et
véhicules électriques et y compris dans
notre chambre d'études du technocentre
une grosse partie des véhicules est
transférée peu à peu collectivement par
petit bout par petit bout tranche dans
notre centre d'études et théâtralisée en
roumanie en corée en inde et peut être
demain dans d'autres pays ça veut dire
que vous craignez donc aujourd'hui pour
votre emploi il y avait donc une
manifestation sur paris également devant
le mondial de l'automobile il ya eu un
rassemblement de délégués de
responsables syndicaux et de personnel
syndical y ait cette manifestation qui a
dégénéré également il ya eu des
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
certains voulaient rentrer dans le parc
des expositions porte de versailles
est ce que est ce que vous regrettez ces
débordements ou est-ce qu'au contraire
vous les comprenez et pensez peut-être
aussi que d'autres pourraient venir
la situation est à ce point tendue alors
je peux toujours comprendre des
débordements je ne fais pas qu'ils
gelaient aujourd'hui la cgt n'appelait
pas l'automobile on a fait un grand
problème avec les distributions massives
de tracts
il ya eu des rassemblements à
l'ouverture des camarades de peverley
aujourd'hui je m'attends au plus tard
j'ai fait qu'il ya des gens de
l'automobile qui était je ne fais pas
exactement de quelles branches qui avant
nous
l'appel vient pas au rassemblement
devant la longue
en tout cas aujourd'hui même si
aujourd'hui il y avait tout de même on a
vu flotter des drapeaux de la cgt
nous n'oublions pas elle suit une
dernière question pour conclure cet
entretien avec vous donc qatar général
cgt technocentre renault
le chiffre d'ailleurs c'est le chiffre
de cette édition j'aimerais votre
réaction 73% 73% des français selon un
sondage paru hier qui sont favorables à
une interdiction des licenciements dans
les entreprises qui réalisent des
bénéfices
aujourd'hui vous demandez quoi vous
demander aux pouvoirs publics de prendre
une mesure justement d'interdire les
licenciements bien sûr bien que depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il allait 2009
année pleine de la crise a été très
difficile
donc voilà on continue de faire des
bénéfices après un il y en a d'autres
dans le domaine public pas forcément
d'automobiles qui licencient alors
qu'ils font des bénéfices
donc bien sûr que les faits j'étais g
l'allemand qui traînent thing contre les
campements boursiers comme on appelle
les lire à l'écran piment qui font
uniquement liée au fait d'augmenter les
les dividendes des actionnaires
merci à nantes ailleurs donc l'un des
responsables de la cgt dans le
département vous étiez en ligne avec
nous après cette mobilisation dans huit
villes de france et du côté de paris
principalement aujourd'hui mobilisation
à l'appel du syndicat cgt et puisque
nous parlons de cette mobilisation
sachet qui hier lundi alain schmitz le
président du conseil général a réuni ces
syndicalistes afin de faire le point sur
la situation dans le département des
solutions concrètes sont elles possibles
les explications d'alice gastines et de
patrick jacques de dixmude ces
syndicalistes du technocentre renault à
guyancourt s'apprêtait en début
d'après-midi à rejoindre paris pour
manifester à l'appel de la cgt à
l'occasion de la journée européenne de
l'industrie
étaient également présents des salariés
de l'usiné renault flins et de peugeot
poissy
la veille lundi le conseil général des
yvelines avait organisé une table ronde
entre syndicats et organisations
patronales pour échanger sur l'avenir de
l'industrie dans le département et faire
des propositions
nous sommes porteurs d'une proposition
de la tenue d'assises industrielle au
niveau départemental qui puisse
regrouper tous les acteurs de la filière
la désindustrialisation n'est pas fatale
elle est le résultat de la crise du
système qui vise à une rentabilité
financière toujours plus importante et
on pensons qu'il ya des choses à faire
pas donc le crédit bancaire de servir au
développement industriel à la recherche
l'intérêt c'est effectivement de
voir comment le conseil général peut
s'impliquer un peu là t'en aller voir
effectivement comment on peut structurer
les actions coordonnées et des peut-être
faire du lobbying c'est un peu le
message aussi qu'il nous a été passée
par rapport à la question effectivement
du transport par rapport à la question
du logement soit pour légal il existe un
outil qui était la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois au niveau de
territoire et ça il faut l'utiliser il
faut l'utiliser aussi au niveau
département ce dont j'avais besoin moi
c'était pas d'avoir des dossiers mais
c'était cette remontée du vécu par les
par les entreprises par les les
les syndicats de ce que vivait le au
quotidien leurs adhérents seul bémol à
cette réunion informelle l'absence des
organisations patronales medef et cgpme
l'industrie représente 16 % de l'emploi
dans les yvelines avec 80 mille postes
soit 2% de moins qu'en 2008
premier acteur toucher les constructeurs
automobiles et leurs sous-traitants